okay it
started wait are we actually live yes
guys oh [__] oh God Lector is not
wearing anything under that trench Co
shut up what's up everybody we are [__]
we are live I was practicing I hadn't
even realized we'd
started likes out the
people God guys are you guys ready now
are you composed not really but yeah
yeah I'm okay welcome everybody to
another Saturday stream here on anime
uproar and as you can tell from if you
just saw Vector live he is wearing a
trench coat Vector Maximus he's wearing
a trench coat to because I promised
people in the Discord that I'd wear it
so there you have it for some reason he
is flashing us with a strench CO he
keeps his promises though got
acknowledge that he made a promise and
he's keeping it and uh yeah so lots of
vector uh fan service happening early on
in the streams it's a new tradition I
think we're gonna have to get them to do
something crazy every single stream
every time we We Begin but welcome
everyone me to like strip naked that's
too far but anything else I won't I
promise that'll be anime oper after dark
it'll be a different uh thing but we'll
we'll keep you guys have to wear
sunglasses though we'll yes we'll keep
you guys posted on that one uh we
joining me today I have my brother Goen
I have Vector Maximus we might get Soul
Maka m and some other peeps just popping
in to hang out and what we're goingon to
be doing in this one is just talking
about some ways to ruin code Gia season
3 and this could be joking things or it
could be serious stuff you're actually
worried about could happen in order to
ruin season 3 so we're gonna be chatting
about that shooting the [__] as we
usually do and having a great time with
some great people welcome everyone in
the chat I already saw Anu in there and
Christian and uh Colonel Matt and ATU
and a bunch of peeps so yeah welcome
guys hello to everyone hello peeps good
to be here
again awkward silence is awkward you
guys notice that when I'm not talking
whenever I'm not talking there's an
awkward silence it's like I I'm carrying
this whole thing all the time well
you're not wrong I'm better at
responding than initiating I like
questions yeah I'm going to have to I'm
going to have to like just like one just
stop start stop talking randomly as an
experiment and just show you guys how as
soon as I stop it's just
like yeah let's just have a stream of
two hours of Silence everyone
go that's what it would be that's what
it would be if it was just the three of
us AR gonna talk on our own I was just
waiting for you to set up like you know
what we're going to be talking about and
kind of giving us a launch board because
you usually do that so we're talking
about today how to mess up code guos and
I was thinking you would give us some
examples of what you think you know some
exemplars generic herum plot generic
Herm plot no oh no that could be done
right the biggest I have uh but no guys
as as you can tell I there is there is a
reason why I'm the leader here but
you're not the leader moving on
co-partner at
best I'm to mute mute goes on guys hold
on one second anyway speaking of me
being the lead my biggest fear of I'm
not gonna really do it
man H my my computer my biggest fear
actually it's ours my biggest fear is
that stop it stop your sibling rivalry
you coward my biggest fear for codas is
that they're gonna make Colin date
[__] Gino Weinberg like honestly that
is my biggest fear right now
that suck petrify me I thought that was
all done in joking in season two you
know like
how Colin and Colin wouldn't give him
the time of day so I mean I hope
not I don't see that happening I feel
like it's more likely that she's killed
off even though I don't want to see it
because I love Colin but I feel like
that's more likely
than than her being with Gino because I
think that would just be terrible I
don't want her to be with oie either I
think that would be bad with
oie or not oie isn't he married yeah he
is
bro if if if Colin and vet are both
gonna be with oie can I be oie
that's I no longer want be
oie yeah anamax willing to give up C2 in
order to have both Colin and Veta oh for
sure oh we have anac doesn't care about
C2 yeah even though she is the most
popular character in K female wise
surpris really and how do you know that
Goen tell us tell us how know that guys
later on a video is coming out that's
going to be top 10
codeos C2 facts that you didn't know
about C2 so it's going to be cool it's
gonna be released probably before five
so look out for that it's gonna be an
exciting one oh my God is that the maut
I don't know what a Mel not is I don't
know I just woke up like the opposite of
a ma
is
oh oh the legendary coffee
mug it's like it's like it's like a
little teacup but it like it gets the it
holds coffee it holds coffee yeah big
welcome to melot missed you in these
streams bro I missed being in the
streams yeah good to have you by the way
I want to shout out to the chat Adriana
asks Nana asks is this stream starting
an hour earlier it's technically not
because there was a time change here in
North America daylight savings time so
that's why there's a time for us it's
noon but in Colombia you don't change
the time so for you it will be different
however for us it's still the same time
and so some parts of the world change
some don't it's weird it's weird just
just don't even question it it just
is we have eno in the chat we have
golden spider Colonel not as I said Noel
spark Hassan Haron he's also on the
Discord what's up bro yeah awesome creep
Ellen hey creep Ellen she's been busy
lately with exams and stuff but we
appreciate you joining us Ryan Fu uh
dead Amelia go change that name
bro devil The Reel oh God he just said
Callum X suzaku oh God though I think
that would just make animac like his
soul would die if that happen yeah okay
well that is a great way actually he's
right that is a great way to ruin cod
cod Gia season 3 like he he was
listening to the topic and he's like
what's the best way to ruin it Colin X2
like great job great job devil the rebel
I have to say that is that would
freaking that would give me nightmares
that would give me actual
nightmares Roland is in
here helian always good to have him
Helen with his Pepe Avatar always here
for a good time I like it I like it natu
fired up is here I I mentioned Christian
I believe corqui V britania A lot of
people man a lot of people I love it I
appreciate it thank you guys for always
coming out to these streams and hanging
out with us and having a good time with
us I we we love the fact that we have
regular peeps that we can chat with hang
out with also hang out on the Discord so
it's a great time yeah Mac let's hand it
over to you because you haven't been on
for a while tell us what's some good
what are some good ways to ruin code GS
season 3 have have any of us in it for
starters that would be that
would I would only add to the
theories yeah I mean okay maybe not
maybe not ruin but I mean it would it
would it could take it down some
interesting paths so for the better for
worse we'd have to find out well I'd be
distracted I wouldn't be taken over the
world I'd be too distracted by things
well if if if Mac was in code guos the
entire show would just revolve around
him streaming so if I
if I had guos it would be like hey you
can take over the world and replace of
Lou and then I'd be like no I command
you to bring me ice cream like right now
that's all it would be like just the
world supply of ice cream right in front
of me and then become a part of me
become ice cream gives you health you
know if he showed up fashionably late
but so then it's just like wait a minute
where is everybody and it's like show's
over we already moved on to something
else
what's up S Bard AKA table [__] can we
get a shout out for table [__] in the
chat guys can we get some love for table
[__] can we get can we get 5,000 likes
can you guys smash that [__]
like button so we can get 5,000 likes
guys why why are you asking why are you
not using your internet
guos guos too much editing that's why oh
that is
true I respect you
more too much to guos you all but don't
make me you know he's already done it
he's already done it glass do it man
yeah but if I did do it you would lose
memory of it so have I
oh
[__] cide table [__] tell us what's up
with you today how you doing I'm doing
good I was I was thinking of something
fun to do to spice up you know what
would ruin Code guos season 3 and for me
me it would be a poor delivery or a
delayed delivery of a certain plot
aspect or plot point I thought what
better way to convey that than to show
up late myself
so well done very metup bro very met yes
I
I'm liveing the
dream something um this is a legitimate
one uh that I think could hurt Code guos
season 3 is I don't want them to pull
like or end up have to do something like
what happens in uh gunam SE Destiny
where they end up like flipping
protagonist because obviously we can't
just instantly jump into Lou doing [__]
you got to build it up and stuff so I'm
just I don't want any decoy
protagonists So like um how exactly do
you mean what I mean he doesn't he
doesn't want like a hunting duck decoy
to be the main character because that
would be that would be too much okay so
start with like a different main
character because Louch is uh you know
hiding right now precisely so obviously
they aren't going to immediately jump to
him you know oh I'm back to being
emperor of Britannia or something like
that no because he's in hiding you've
obviously got to build up to when he
comes out of hiding so I just don't want
there to be any illusions that this show
is not about
Lou because it is about
Louch yeah it's true but they they are
gonna have to build up to it though I
feel because you know you can't just be
like oh all the stuff that happened with
the zero recum now we undid it right oh
yeah I've got no doubt on that I just
don't want them to basically try to sell
the first part of the series as somebody
else is now the main protagonist yeah
especially if it's a bad like character
yeah particularly if that's the case I
think um oh yeah Amelia changed his name
to Alive Amelia so I appreciate that man
I appreciate now I don't have to put you
in timeout
anymore I'm just waiting for black
critic guy to show up so I can put him
in timeout oh come on come on over come
on black guy he whenever we go on his
channel and say anything he puts us in
timeout to feel powerful but that's
because abuse that's because he's scared
of us scared of our Anu is here Anu I
appreciate your work uh did a great job
of moderating the stream big stream we
did the book roast you did a good job
that was awesome we had that was a crazy
we had like 150 people watching at one
time it was nuts it was nuts we're
approaching 2,000 views on that already
and that anime snob actually joined us
later on in the Stream and that was
pretty crazy so yeah that was very fun
that was the biggest and funnest Rand
Cafe especially because Mac wasn't there
wow my feelings right here that's where
you hit me right here that implies you
have
them oh wow H devil the rebel re in a
I'm not reading that I'm reading it it
says Goen over animac but Mac is number
uno uno number Uno heart smiley face
heart smiley face heart smiley face I
gave you your title I animac no one else
hey hey hey thanks thanks D I love you I
appreciate it too
nice fight devil the rebel we're we're
still getting that money not Max so
that's the important thing
yeah well here here's an interesting
question and this is you donate $100 for
Mac please show how much you love Mac
right now by donating money donate $100
and they'll make sure 10 cents gets to
Mac at least at least 15 that's my deal
cents I'm okay with that no but yeah we
do appreciate the donations uh Dev the
rebel because like I said we never even
asked for donations we didn't even know
that was an option and then he started
just donating supporting us so that that
means a lot man we appreciate it I'm not
going to read stupid [__] like Goen over
animac however I do appreciate you read
it and it was good it was
great and the Lord animac read it and it
was the exact same
thing so cods let's r i see finder bear
and original Inc in here as well they're
active on the Discord what's up guys
welcome well C cold actually posed an
interesting question uh this actually
would go to V as well as for the rest of
us Lou is a character was pretty much
complete in development so how much of a
focus should Louch have for this do you
think there is going to be still more to
develop because obviously this is a
whole new thing that's going to be
happening if he's coming back but how
much should he be focused on in season
three well I I feel like he should still
be um the main character I mean I can
agree that his character development
kind of it it went it came full circle
by the end of code guos so I don't
really feel like there's a need for a
ton of character development for Louch
himself maybe show how he's adjusting to
life as an immortal like I think there
could be room for character development
in that you know like how C2 over years
had to cope with it by basically
becoming
emotionless uh and you could supplement
more character development and show how
you know like the difficulties just the
normal people are having adjusting to
this new piece World CU it's hard to
switch from that kind of always War
mentality to that peace time
mentality particularly for
soldiers but peace fun oh wow can't
can't English peace time is fun time
there we go nailed it yeah but it comes
with like a feeling of a lack of purpose
for for soldiers people who have been
fighting their whole life you know like
people like Cornelia like I imagine she
would have a hard time
adjusting yeah no that's just it is his
whole character was building up to that
and adjusting to it and then obviously
with peace now it's going to become a
massive change for him and I do think
that would be important to to convey to
cover um obviously he wouldn't need as
much screen time but I do think it's
important that we do see that because
that is huge as we've seen him build up
to that point so that adjustment will be
just as interesting especially for Louch
as a
character so so that's that's going to
be really interesting which I guess uh
begs the question then is you
know who would they have to focus on for
to to ruin the show who do you think in
terms of the cast if they focused on
instead would be a I guess not
necessarily a good
choice
yes yam Tamaki tamaki's cool man leave
Tamaki alone like yeah but he wouldn't
make it he's a good hoing character not
a good main character Yeah well yeah I
don't I don't think they would ever make
him a main character that would be
ridiculous uh something devil the rebel
said was wait to ruin season 3 have
Louch show up like at the end of the
last episode and that's
iTouch DX
Louch yeah yeah I feel like I'd be upset
if anyone but Louch was the main
character to be honest I can't see a way
around Louch being the main character
especially because he is the most
popular like anime character of all time
so not emphasizing that not milking it I
feel like would be a bad thing
surprisingly particularly since his name
is in the title of the Season exactly
exactly it's like we don't mention him
guys but what if but what if he shows up
right at the end and then season 3 is
only just a promo for season
4 but it can't really be called a
season I definitely watch it but
still I wouldn't be happy anime world
says the way to ruin season 3 is to have
them announce that season 3 is just a
movie instead of a season yeah well I
don't know if it was a good movie I mean
I don't even even so man even so like I
want I want the 25 episodes oh yeah so
do I so do I the thing is like a lot of
people in the chat were talking about
budget and whether they're gonna have a
good budget and like I feel like they
have to because first of all they're
selling merchandise like crazy on the
website if we've been checking their
website and there's constantly updates
about new merchandise no release dates
unfortunately but new merchandise is
selling new uh you know special events
they're having an Akihabara for code gas
they're so they're selling money they
have a huge fan base
uh the lch was voted most popular anime
character recently in Japan C2 was the
most popular female character so yeah
there's a lot of Buzz there's a lot of
fan there a huge fan base
internationally there's a lot of
merchandise being sold so if anyone
should have a good budget for this it
should be code gas I mean come on I
think because of the hype for it too
their like their funding is going to be
like at the top yeah think they're gonna
be good budget Wise It's GNA be good
yeah I'd be I agree I would be very
surprised if they don't have a fairly
large budget you have3 doar to make this
happen make it good team well they
didn't have a big budget for like the
other ones like they kept messing them
over that's one of the things that uh
even too spooky mentioned in his video
about facts about coas like the studio
Sunrise wasn't really good to the
director they kind of made it a [__] to
work on the project so hopefully now
there's been enough time for them to
realize okay this is real [__] we got to
put everything we got into this and
respect the
director that's what I shout out to
Spooky gonna be on Rand Cafe this coming
week as a special guest so yeah guys if
you uh didn't know Rand Cafe is every
Thursday 5:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
on our Channel and that there we just
ran r with a bunch of guest YouTubers
kind of like this just ranting about all
sorts of different anime it's always
such a pleasure so be sure to tune in
and of course if you're not on the
Discord server you can join our Discord
server Link in the description there we
will tell you about all the updates you
will be the first to know and you can
chat with us and we're super cool and
spend way too much time there including
melut and table
coup he's right I live there now that's
an interesting
point uh gozen that's a really
interesting point to discuss there is
you I mean that's budget is a huge thing
obviously you know is the more time goes
on the more expensive shows become in
terms of making them and of course we
all know that the first two seasons of
code guos were not exactly easy for the
staff on that show to work with so maybe
that is part of what they're doing right
now maybe that is a tester to see how
many people are buying merchandise how
many people are interested in buzzing
about it you know maybe that's going to
start dictating is maybe that's why
they've been promoting it so early
despite the fact we haven't heard
anything in several
months yeah that's a good point
too I wonder if they're waiting for like
this onslaught of support but I feel
like you know what more can we do what
more can we do I mean we could start a
kick uh Kickstarter to send money to
them that's what they're waiting for
we're so poor though it's not even that
it's just how the anime industry works
because look at the seven deadly s right
they have a huge fan base there's a lot
of you know people can't wait for the
next season but it's just because the
production is is so slow because of the
certain ways the industry works and
that's why there is no season two yet
not because there's not enough money not
because there's not enough support it's
just like there's all these I don't know
it's just the way the industry Works
they're very they keep postponing things
like you saw with Attack on Titan right
postpone for four years come on like if
are we gonna say Attack on Titan didn't
make enough money are we gonna say
attack didn't have a fan base and yet it
was still delayed for four years right
so the thing is it's just it's just how
the industry works there's some issues
with the industry manga thing happening
though like they wanna they want to let
the manga go as long as possible before
they kind of start and stop the train
like continuously but with code guos
like that shouldn't be a problem right
so that's another consideration well
it's it's interesting because and I
talked about this before because you
made you made a really good point any ma
is that schedules you're us usually the
case they'll generally in uh they
generally will have something in
production for a period of time before
it actually starts releasing but then
usually the case is then they'll
announce it or then they'll start kind
of putting promotional images out you
very rarely take that route and it's
with Attack on Titans another really
interesting one because originally
everyone
expected uh zombie trains to basically
be season two of Attack on Titan and
it's from from what little I've UND
stood is that essentially Attack on
Titan was pushed back to release that
instead so it's it's really curious to
know what they're doing with this and
kind of where they're going I mean I I
like I said I do believe a lot of it
simply has to come down to production
scheduling I would hate to find out
because of the fact that they're like
hey you know the production's already
screwed up again that's why they're
struggling with this so that would that
would be terrible but yeah no it's it's
interesting it's it's very
interesting yeah and a few people
mentioned
orange if uh Orange died that that would
be ridiculous but yeah I feel I we I we
talked about it before and that would
definitely I don't want that is awesome
but I'm afraid it might because of the
PV and and that's something that
wouldn't like it wouldn't be like you
know death not to hell you know like I
feel like they could save it after that
while if they killed off like a more
important character like C2 or or
something then that would be ridiculous
yeah or Colin or something no [__] that
uh odwin says that they could ruin it by
having C season 3 have a whole bunch of
plot holes like Akito did and I agree
Akito did have a lot of plot holes and
character development issues yeah it
depends what they go off of do they go
off of like pure emotion and then they
don't want us like think about it
logically and just like let's make a
kickass show or are they going to be
careful with the planning and focus also
on making a logical story that doesn't
have plot holes cuz you can have like
you have some good shows that have
occasional plot holes but like you you
don't care as much because it's just
overall a good show so we'll see what
happens hey Bill gun Alex are you here
can you hear me bro can you look behind
me what's that what's that it's your
it's a books no no no black black bro
how's that how's that for Comm aard
how's this how's this bro
yeah yeah no he's a he's a guy who
watched the the snob stream and then he
was like man like he didn't like my a
criticism of um snobs protagonist
because he's like a Shinji whereas I
want more like communist style
protagonist so we had a little debate in
in the comments it was
fun but yeah like uh you're right though
Bill Gan you're right that my critique
of Cher is subjective because I look at
who I relate to so it's definitely
subjective
but I still you know I wanted to make my
points to snob but I understand his
perspective as well of course and that
was a fun stream wasn't it that was fun
as [__] that was a blast that was really
cool yeah table was the only one only
one there because all these other guys
are too busy watching Gundam to read
snom's book this is
true all of us argue with that though
depending on season Gundam uh well soul
and I are working through Zeta right now
so oh good stuff all right that that's
worth it
then there's just so much I don't even
know where to like where to start but z
z is supposed to be good isn't it yeah
double O is good yeah double O I don't
even
know Z zero or the original series it's
twice as good as code g clearly two
Zer oh good point yeah some some guy is
telling us he's the Messiah or in the
chat I'm I'm sorry bro I'm
sorry I wouldn't want to be the Messiah
either I'm sorry dude sounds way too
stressful that sounds like a lot of work
oh wait how to ruin code guos Jesus
Christ shows up at the end and just says
everybody stop fighting they all become
friends that's it or pull off a seven
deadly sins and just like guys everyone
you thought was dead magic and they're
back
know like at the end of the series Jesus
shows up and like snaps his fingers okay
it's time for the
Rapture you know what Charles was right
we're just gonna have one Consciousness
and you guys can go [__]
yourselves well e even though Jesus is
our true king please stop bringing him
into this okay bringing him into this
crazy crazy train of uh we're not
insulting
Jesus no I know but I'm just saying
the stream is going a little a little
cuckoo in that sense Blasphemous don't
they all yeah it's true all our streams
go go crazy and if I if we can get some
hashtag we are not a cult in the chat
that would be as well we need to clarify
keep keep the feds yeah like now we got
a guy claiming he's the Messiah in our
chat like how are
we oh we need more hashtags we are not a
cult guys we need to make this more
clear I I put one in don't worry can you
can you just let me design anime oper
merch and you can have a shirt that just
says not a cult on the side yes it' be
great your little logo on it as long as
you for
free my life is working for
free I feel like that I feel like that
would be like man I think these guys
might be a
cult no no no that's just it we're we're
not we're not it says right here not a
cult not a cult if we say we're not
we're not we wear robes that are meeting
but we're not a cult yeah but it's just
because we like wearing robes they're
comfortable they're honestly are like
one of those long hoods like it's really
good exactly we might chant a little bit
we might chant but that's just our wake
up ritual it's normal it's normal I do
that with my coffee I chant before I
drink it I thought you bathed in it but
whatever what that comes after Vector
why would you jump the gun and assume I
just go right to bathing in my this guy
how dare you how dare you I can't even I
I'm done I'm done with you Vector okay
you you not kidding take it back I love
you it's like vector don't go I was
joking just gets up and
leaves I always win says a good way to
ruin Cod is you would have like every
important character just die at the end
yeah that would suck well like okay kill
them all we'll see what happens but at
the
end is not as bad as in the middle you
know so we shall
like what happens because I don't want
them to die but at the same time I feel
like as long as like Louch the first
code Gia season 2 I was okay with it
because at least it was at the end right
even though he wasn't dead but if he was
de I'd be okay with it because it was at
the end but if it was in the middle of
the Season I'd be like no yeah and and
you never know everyone could die and if
there's some sort of like important
message or like a Mor big moral of the
story or something it could it could
work I'm hoping but hey animac be like
it could be like the real ending of
Evangelion
animac is the movie the end of the
ultimate ending bro no that is the real
that is the true ending that is the true
ending ending goes why do you like being
wrong why do you always disagree I just
feel like that was that was catering to
this is not evangelon Evel the first
ending disc the endings of Evangel okay
okay yeah yeah let's sh on this whole
gos and stuff anyway what I was thinking
based on what we were talking before we
somehow got on evangelon which I don't
even know anymore um is that basically
way it could end is that everyone dies
Louch becomes really bitter and
depressed at the world and decides
Ragnarok was a good idea and since he's
with C2 they both decide to initiate
Ragnarok and basically it subverts
everything he he stood for in season two
yeah that would be that would be like
gan's ridiculous view of the End of
Evangelion where he thinks that the true
ending is the
Ragnarok everybody
ends did an original ending for us I
just feel like called It's called The
End of Evangelion the end some research
man it's an alternate ending these fans
who were upset with the original ending
preach s preach yes it's true it was
made by the fans no it was made for the
fans because they were complaining about
it and that's why the reason basically
going to give my two cents the reason
why they didn't have evang End of
Evangelion in the original series was
because they ran out of money to animate
the damn thing it's not true oh yes true
research that is true that is true the
director said that was the original
ending I'm gonna give my two cents I've
never watched
evangelon you should get out of here
yeah by the way I encourage people who
care to just go research it by the way
yeah actually uh animac right Vector
right goes in wrong
older brothers are always right however
this is a good thing because
end can you stop Goen interrupting uh
when we to do these streams these code
get we end up talking about a lot of
other anime so I was wondering I want
you guys to let me know in the chat in
the Discord later whatever um what other
anime you would like to talk about in
streams because I feel like the big
reason the code guos Community here has
been growing and we've built such a
strong Community which is Awesome by the
way thank you everybody is that that
people needed wanted to talk about Cod
because there's so much to talk about
about cod in terms of the philosophy and
the world and the characters but there
was no great platform to do it right you
know you could either do on Reddit or
like a forum and then you would have to
wait for someone to reply maybe no one
replies at all whereas here we have a
channel where we you know we stream live
we address your comments in the chat we
have a Discord we can talk about in the
Discord we have like anime theories chat
and all this different stuff where we
can you know exchange theories talk
about the characters meme the crap out
of it right so I feel like it filled a
need especially for coas but like you
guys think that there's other anime that
you would like to talk about such as
Evangelion which I think is also another
one of those anime that keeps you
thinking long after it finishes airing
just like KS so if there are let us know
in the chat let us know in the Discord
what other animes you would like to kind
of discuss in this sort of platform
because that would be fun as
well and Eno said something cool Eno
said the way to ruin it ruin season 3
would be that it turns out in SE that in
episode one of uh Cod Gas Louch was in a
car accident he was in a coma the whole
time just dreaming this whole
thing well at the very least then when
he wakes up he can go back to Ashford
and like reconcile with Nell provided
that the provided that he's not just
dreaming up the whole ke codeos world
yeah and that you know it's like when he
was going with Revol somewhere that's
when he got in the coma oh my God Louch
is really Subaru yes
oh he's like I thought I was so cool
there for a while but but it wasn't no
it turns out I'm a
loser in real life um so in the chat
they're saying they should have an
animac versus go and roast battle he
doesn't want it guys he doesn't want
that [__] bring
it no yeah please please go go in what
kind of battle bro what kind of battle
you want rap battle you want a rap
battle you want a karoke battle you want
well we let people
decide people decide or democracy style
or have a real battle with swords and
Spears and horses this is why we don't
make you let you make executive
decisions and that's why you're a
smarter man than I because I let me make
executive decisions and it it screws
things up it's bad it's
bad yeah I don't I don't know Vector
this is why see this is why vector likes
me more because Goen is like democracy
what is this democracy
thing hey man the United States of
Japan gler Cordo what's up bro I really
appreciated your comment on the video on
the uh code gas latest codeos video man
means a lot to me such a pleasure to
have you here as part of the community I
love having you like I I've met so many
of you guys I consider you friends I
consider you comrades it's a pleasure to
you know have built this community and
have you guys a part of it and yeah Goen
you can get your own two cents in as
well or two pounds Reb so much yeah the
rebel on the
matter or Canadian dollars or whatever
it next Thursday live
stream oh yeah but you guys if you have
any cool ideas for what you want us to
do let us know it can happen but C
thanks again man I think that comment on
the video was amazing and it touched me
man it touched me all right actual
medieval Jou could be very cool thank
you yes yes and we can totally we can
totally like make that happen we have
the resources we do now you just made
like four pounds today that's that's
enough we are we are also Serbian so we
must have it in the house at all
Ting javelins and all that of course
every Serbian I know
does says doofy dude says we should do a
dance battle because we might be
terrible at danc
we are so bad that would be good that's
where you're wrong animac has been
taking Selsa lessons don't make him
dance yeah I feel like at the end of
this me and animac will be the real
losers I've been threatening what do you
mean at the
end I've been threatening to start salsa
dancing for people because I've been
taking lessons um you w want to see it
guys you don't want to see it's vector's
nightmare I can't
un there he but yeah this stream is
brought to you by devil the rebel who
enjoys to get me and Goen to go after
each other almost as much as
gawk gawk Crobat gawk on the server is
always talking [__] trying to get a he's
like anim can I be your server
brother and it's like but Goen likes
Dragon Ball super that's not a good
anime and yet and yet crad G didn't like
kill aill Goen didn't like kill aill I
loved kill aill so clearly the I need to
clarify some things after you said all
those things okay so first of all I
appreciate Dragon Ball super for what it
is I'm not saying it's code guos I'm not
saying it's death no but I appreciate it
for what it is and it's nostalgic and I
watch it with my best friend and we just
like talking about it uh and what was
the second thing he said that you hated
kill I didn't hate kill a kill but I
think animac overhyped it I did prefer L
on a lot more and I feel like it was
almost like I want to be gr Lon kind of
thing but yeah that's just my take on it
but I didn't hate it for sure so did you
did you also think little witch Academia
was a wannabe G and Lon because it was
made by trigger like what are you
talking about no we watched that and we
both liked it and I thought it was cool
how it reminded me of Harry Potter meets
anime it was fun yeah I wonder who said
that first uh my
girlfriend no I said it's like Harry
Potter meets uh Kiki's Delivery Service
that was me I wanton that credit I don't
know txell gaming says we should do a
singing Battle of KS opening one Colors
by flow oh will do it man I've beat him
before I've beaten him before in a
battle of this is not fair he asked a
friend and animac is like older than me
so he has like Prestige with my friend
sometimes so my friend felt pressured to
vote for him that was the truth okay so
by the way this friend that he's talking
about is the same best friend he watches
Dragon Ball super with his best friend
we're friends too of course but the one
he said that is his best friend said
that I won the Kow battle yes so yeah
good game goes in GG buddy I disagree GG
I'm not saying this friend has good
taste in
singing all right so code
gas
that one thing I guess we better get
back onto it what is being on topic all
of the mechs where aprons go bad or good
idea all of the what mechs wear aprons
yeah all of the they're called nightmare
frames mac oh my God okay
then all the nightmare frames where
apron Vector oh man yo natu fired up
says we should do a Mech battle be lot
though I gota
say and Goen in the Lancelot I would not
be in lot I feel that's not fair G and
loggin are so overpowered particularly
no I I accept I accept I
accept I will be one punch man and you
can be the gur Lon and we'll see what
happens would that work do you think
that would work like would he be able to
one punch the G Logan like spiral power
he's a he's a gag manga like he could
definitely do it he could definitely do
it because it's unrealistic he doesn't
he doesn't follow any rules he can kill
anything with one punch or beat anything
with one
punch something that throws
galaxies I mean the premise is he can
defeat anything so this is the thing
this is the thing guys you don't
understand spoiler alert the secret
source of sa's power is spiral power
okay but one
punch
period there is no
counter except maybe Avalon my counter
is gonna shave my head it's happening
we're gonna do the one punch Man versus
gr Lon battle let me let me just uh let
me just remind you that the Dark Matter
thieves ship is just a regular spaceship
nothing close to the tang toag laga and
he needs consecutive regular punches to
take out that guy so yeah it's not just
one punch you know yeah so imagine if he
wasn't doing like nonserious punches
from the beginning he would have taken
that guy out easily at the beginning so
if he hasn't even like shown a
percentile of his
power so I'm just gonna point that out
so you can't judge it from that
yeah devil theb like super serious punch
that would be insane okay go devil the
rebel is like who started this battle
stuff yeah I wonder [__] wonder who
started this it was Evangelion man like
that's how good the show is it's
sparking the passionate like did you
hear Vector like passionate [__] the
yeah like I don't hear Vector getting
passionate about [__] but
like it's like the way it works is that
I can put up with [__] to a massive
degree and then I just explode
you're like no
no by the way basically Eno is really
hyped up in the chat she's just
challenging people to fight her she's
like fight me fight me consecutive punch
man consecutive punch man doesn't have
quite the same ring to it no it
doesn't well nope okay here we go it's a
goodsy one in the end
man that would be a very anticlimactic
show yeah we should we should do a
battle in uh who can do better Koke for
one punch man opening one
punch I think I won that now you go then
I think I just won I think I just won
though yeah let's see your one yeah you
each need to do your best one punch how
are
they I feel like I'm gonna rape all your
ears but one
punch I won there we go and now and now
get out the straw pole and we'll vote on
who got had the better one
punch God oldwin this the stream is
still about Cod Gas we're talking about
which openings we should from codos we
should sing and stuff it's still about
Cod is obviously a subsection of codos
and do let us know what other anime you
want to discuss so like Gundam we have
Gundam Fanatics here including vector
and soul Maka and I'm a fan I'm a fan of
Gundam too yeah like I like Gundam I
haven't seen them all though but I like
certain ones and but like vtor soak are
huge Gundam fan so if you guys want to
talk some Gundam let us know Evangelion
of course showing you why Goan is wrong
um yeah all all that sort of stuff I I
really this is gonna be funny we're
gonna have like counter videos we're
gonna be like we're gon have like anamax
take and we're gonna have like Goen
response yeah like the on the same
channel it's split personality YouTube
channel yes you know a good way to ruin
Code guia season 3 is if Code guia
season 3 didn't actually do anything
related to Cody seasons one and
two didn't an didn't melut predict that
it was going to be Slice of
Life he did in fact he has a whole video
on that so or at least a whole like 15
seconds of the video versions were kind
of bad except like not like funny but
like were would have been would have
sucked in real life except for the Goku
one where like they go to heaven and he
has to fight Goku and Kam like that
would have been epic to see actually
would have been kind of cool it would
have been kind that would have been
really
cool well first of all no one can [__]
with Comina like let's not joke about
okay man like enough of your homoerotic
relationship with Kina
man ripy it's that's that's that's
Bromance you know what romance is
allowed to flourish romance has to
flourish see I'm comfortable with myself
Goen what about you I don't know anymore
with those those low blow insults I
don't know
anymore I don't know who you are devil
the rebel brought out the worst than you
I am your blood it's a shame I am in you
fire in is my
blood oh yeah Panda gazebo just reminded
me guys it's over
9,000 we're over 9,000 subscribers we
just crossed it like yesterday how crazy
is that and you're already at
9,150 so fast grow sorry back there go
oh I was about to say that if you just
hit 9,000 yesterday you're already at
9,152 so yeah
exactly we're gonna have an Easter egg
in the new video that's coming out today
and I think you guys will appreciate it
if you like I I imagine it's something
to do with the over 9,000 meme this is
this is might be true I don't know see
you can either the memes spoiler
alerts jeez would have appreciated some
kind of warning tag
thanks warning this video contains the
dankest of internet
memes watch at your own all the memes
all
them I swear that's become a
meme I know I know I like it I like it
yeah so do
I devil the rebel says one thou 10,000
subs and we get goes into to wear a m
outfit I'm down for that
no guys come on come on just humiliation
combo line at least at least 20,000 guys
no kid no we're the thing this is the
thing
guys of course ma will do it for free
can't we just have ma do it yeah he'll
do it atth for trust me um by the way
guys um again thank you so much for your
support and if you keep supporting us
and telling your friends and sharing the
channel if we get big enough then even
if they're like you know we're not going
to make cod season we're just gonna make
a movie we can be like no no [__] that
bro we're making the season we're
financing it we're protesting naked
outside the studio if you don't do it
like we're making it
happen power we have the more we can
influence the world so yeah spread the
support let's do it and Mac yes don't
shake your head because you are
protesting naked with us if it comes to
that if it comes to that man I was
shaking my head in agreeance I already
said like I'm I'm already protesting
naked outside their HQ already season
mut's way of protesting is sitting in
front of his computer with coffee that's
uh that's the truest form of protest
ever truest purest yeah most effective
for sure definitely you don't want to
get cold it's Canada you know it's true
true I go I could die die it's
true it's sadly true Lan says we should
make our own season 3 in the forms of
those uh what what they're
called flash specials or like you know
the the audio dramas or something I
don't know we are making a Discord
fanfic we're making a fanfic on the
Discord by the way Discord link is in
the description if you want to join us
we're almost at 750 members now it's
crazy we're just it's I I don't know if
there's any more active code gas
Community out there really than us
that's that interactive there better not
be find them like I know the code GS
Reddit is pretty active but like Reddit
is not as interactive as we are here
like we they don't do they can't do
streams they don't have a Discord that's
like this active so yeah yeah man it's
awesome watch anime together
but the thing is a fanfic is being
written on the Discord that's that's
kind of like based on you know the
britanian Royal lines
but members of the Discord rather
than you know people from code guos but
we got they're gonna have guos powers
and stuff so yeah I don't know maybe one
of those fanfic is gonna be so good that
they're gonna make it into incorporate
into season three they're gonna be like
these guys are
geniuses it it will find our fan fiction
will be the fleshed out history of
Britannia we have like
nothing we've got lots of History we've
got lot of inaccurate and inconsistent
history we got a lot of speculation but
it's history might be fake history but
it's history Nat to Nat to ask do we
want a shout out on Instagram and I'll
just tell you we want all the shout outs
all of
them also Eno is like join us join us I
feel like that's not helping our Weir
not a cult thing but yeah appreciate
it
but I mean we're not a
cult we are not a cult we are not a cult
we chant it every morning every
evening in front of our Shrine that's
definitely not from our in front of our
cultist
Shrine salmon of Doubt how to make codas
amazing make DX fan the writer uh please
no DX would probably say something like
I would kill myself before writing for
code guos knowing DX yeah but then he
can write out that long intensive chess
game
yes like yeah we could have an alternate
episode one where it's like an hour
special just the the long chess game
thex fan style but the thing is though
guys I'm the writer here guys I'm the
writer here why do you think DX fan
would write better than
me do do you think I should challenge DX
fan to a write off
yeah I don't know how that would be very
very uninteresting unless you got like
the Death Dome creators to do it well
that is an interesting point now that
you have currently won your
battle with snob does that mean that
you're going after DX
next just go you know I had a lot of fun
in the snob stream and I I like that you
said that I won the battle because I
always think I win especially that
battle with go and over Evangelion that
was a especially that battle with
that was like a 5c knockout
punch it only took one
punch but yeah I would definitely be
down to you know do some uh drama debate
with DX fan because it's a lot of fun
and of course I don't take it personally
I'm sure he doesn't take it personally
but it would be a lot of fun to just do
some debating we'll see we'll see it
would be cool table [__] what do you
think
I'd be de with
that I I know that I know that my my
supporters my nights would be behind me
so like if there was like a live debate
I don't think there would be any chat it
would just be all hell animac just like
spamming the chat and all the DX fans
are like but no
but but there is more of us because
there is 3 34,000 but no we are more
active we are we are determined and we
are not a cult
always make sure to add on that last bit
otherwise people get the wrong
idea yeah people on Discord are starting
to call me roast toac because I'm just
like roasting people but damn it's it's
fun it's all good fun and it's uh you
know it's engaging it's debate nowadays
people don't want to debate anymore no
one wants to disagree they're like I'll
just do my own thing you do your own
thing but debating is fun and you learn
certain things from a debate that you
wouldn't learn if the debate didn't
happen so I think it's
F another good way to ruin kodas instead
of having Mecca just have them debate on
YouTube wasn't that the whole point of
the Federation of
Nations animac we do a chess match to
[Music]
decide suggested suggested by Helen
superable I don't know how to say it
but Helen super able I I apologize for
that
but
yes that would that would be that would
be cool that would be very code guos
esque I feel like feel like I'm ready if
you are bro and then immediately after
the chess match you get in giant robots
and you race yes but anac no throwing
pieces
okay I don't know if I mentioned him yet
but I see you all the time bro thanks
for sticking with us and supporting us
we love you um go no I'm not a big fan
of uh playing chess with Goen he has
done it much more he has more
experience however
gozen will not face me in karoke because
he knows I'm better he will not so me
have halfway meet halfway a karaoke CH
will not face me in a rap battle he will
not face me in a rap battle he will not
face me in a wrof because bro I set him
down I set him down just need to
establish it HS match karaoke WR
off dance off rap battle match off all
together you know says that I that I
would flip the board uh in no that would
never happen this is that's that's
funny
kamakazi that's
my
Champion I am the champion in both risk
and Mario party so should should we go
into I'm not even gonna go into what I'm
the current champion in which is
actually all sports all other games and
chess actually I I'm in water polo no
I'm a stronger I'm a stronger swimmer
you know it neither of us ever played I
I feel like but I don't know anyways
code gas
g should they have water polo in COD gas
that is a good question that that like
if like free that would ruin it for me
so if we're talking about things that
would ruin code guos if we stopped
getting fan service from the ladies and
just got freees fan service from Louch
and so you're saying a way to ruin Code
guia season 3 would be to make it into a
free spin-off but not not with the free
characters but where they basically
nightmares night nightmare fan service
well swimming playing water polo it's
like you can't wear clothes while you're
in the nightmare musley nightmare men
swimming like in iron blooded orphans
when they're on on but that doesn't
bother me too much they don't they don't
put in your face uh an says drop aite
guys for animac versus Goen giant robot
chess
battle now I'm just imagining animac and
Goen fighting but in it's it's a giant
chess board where it's got nightmare
frames and like they each have Colin for
the queen piece man do you know how bad
I was looking for uh code guos andp CH
oh I know I was also looking I couldn't
find one I I just wish I just wish
someone would make it so I could buy the
[__] out of it and it looks like a
pretty cool design for chess the pieces
that they use in the series yeah it
annoys me I want to I wanted to make one
like somehow if I had like money or
something I would make one where it's
like you have the chess pieces where
like
characters are certain things so like
you know louo is the king C2 is the
queen stuff like that like
Colin could be the Knight something like
that and versus the Branan side so so
Charles as the king Mariana as the queen
like that would be amazing yeah except
no one would freaking want to be Charles
side like that would suck I would
morally lose like before I even began no
you could put like a schneizel
perhaps for the enemy King CU he look sh
at least looks cool there's at least
that
aspect yeah mikazuki is pretty op um TX
gaming is talking about mikazuki from
Iron blood orphans he's pretty op but
then also he pays a heavy
price for his uh when he fights to you
know full force so in that sense I feel
like it's kind of it gets back to the
whole consequences of your actions
because he pays a heavy price so yeah
iron blood orphan is definitely a good
show I would recommend
it professional soccers like Nal League
can be a pawn that can't move that's
just that's just mean man oh I mean at
the very least you can push the
wheelchair she can roll her wheelchair
it's mean say can't move at all like
electronically too yeah and that's the
question can Will Nan be able to walk in
the sequel because you know M she's
going to become a cyborg yeah I don't
know if she's gonna play a big role but
like I feel like I can't really get
excited about not only playing a big
role but I don't know we'll see I'm
hyped for Nell I'm like hell yeah give
me give more n as soon as I heard season
3 I'm like holy [__] n back man life
complete cyber cyborg Empress Nell hype
he could totally prove me wrong though
like I don't know but we'll
see well n only like she broke Charles's
guos right so it all depends whether she
W she couldn't walk because of part of
the guos or if it was really Medical but
I feel like with the technology that the
britannians have in terms of medical
care and now her breaking the gas they
might make her walk in the next season I
think the reason why she couldn't walk
at least um the eyesight was from
Charles's guos but for the legs I think
it was because the nerves in her spinal
cord were broken so it can't connect
with her
legs yeah but that's yeah that would be
a permanent damage but I don't know if
that's actually happen I don't think we
ever had that confirmed right I thought
we did but I'm I'm just going for memory
so maybe I'm wrong yeah like I don't
think I don't think uh spinal damage was
actually
confirmed because yeah like that would
make sense if it was but I don't think
they ever actually confirmed it some
things are just like like they're not
get confirmed because it's like who
gives a [__] you know point is she can't
walk everyone everyone this just did
spinal damage was confirmed it is
permanent she will never walk again
imagine imagine the voice actress is
like yeah so so we've gone into detail
about the condition of Nal and whether
she'll be able to walk again
but uh so code guos ruining I think
we're doing pretty good at it so far I
think I think we ruined the [__] out of
it so far but let's keep going yeah guys
in the chat any other ideas about how to
ruin season 3 you know why you the
soundtrack I'd say oh sorry yeah I read
a thing an article I like it could be
like you know [__] because it's it's
an article you know you can't trust
those things necessarily but they said
that C2 is younger in it's she's gonna
be like look younger in the sequel and
they don't know if it's because of
Animation or because something happens
but I think that that sounds like a
pretty stupid idea like I do not want
her to look younger I don't know what
that would be okay
Mac all you Mac no I'm I'm agreeing I I
don't I don't want her to be younger
yeah I don't I don't see that that would
serve no purpose and I really hope and
if they go okay this would ruin it if
they go for a younger audience like that
would really ruin it for me it would
yeah yeah like if they if they kind of
try and like pull a like pull a Marvel
and just like I and I get it like I get
why people do that like you obviously
want to appeal to everybody but if they
uh they like Disney ised it is that a
word Disney ised disy is now it is now
oh yeah uh but yeah either that or if
they made it like really like MO like
just like really Moy like etchy just
like take away all the action aspects
and just like it's true it it is it is a
balance although like obviously like any
any man I do appreciate ety Tastefully
done Tastefully but yeah it is a balance
for sure yeah um by the way alive Amelia
said a good thing he's like have Nina
die that would be a way to ruin codia
season three everyone loves think I
think she's safe because no one would
give a [__] think would be very
if he lost Nina
so I think table had no say in what
happened to be hon would be a good
character Arc for table okay so let's
let's solve this right now let's solve
this right now we have tun here with
us he didn't want to talk about the
incident the incident for many years
because it was traumatic but let's ask
him right now guys table [__] how did
you feel during that scene how did you
feel in that
moment how do you feel now about Nina
and everything that
happened well it's um it's very
interesting and I'm glad you asked I'm
I'm in a good point in my life to where
I'm comfortable talking about this
publicly so uh for for the first time I
will I'll get into some personal
information here so what a lot of people
don't realize is that I actually gained
sentience during that moment so my first
experience in this world was while that
was occurring it was
awkward um lot lot of sleepless nights
lot of counseling but nonetheless I've
I've been able to make my way through
that and make my understanding with that
in peace with it uh you know I've been
able to talk with nah we understand that
that was a phase in her life but it was
also an
expression that can't be denied
it's it's really important to understand
that nah was coming from a good place
she was at a frustrated point in her
life I was the table that just gained
sentience you know both of them are very
challenging Endeavors that some people
just face in life and I mean that's just
it everybody goes through different
experiences I'm sure there's somebody
else out there gone through the same
thing I want you to know that you're not
alone okay may maybe maybe you've done
things to a table and that table gained
intelligence and then started talking as
well you know you're okay
it's okay but the thing
is
that we were able to Blossom a
relationship from it we connected we
understood one another and we realized
that we were actually quite similar you
know I me that's just the thing is at
the end of the day a whether you're a
table or or a person it doesn't matter
because you know we're all the
same
yes God bless you table God you're a
brave table that was
amazing out of 10 by the way
professional slacker says the table
you're the next hentti protagonist and
uh I dig it also I appreciate the
complex you know view you gave it wasn't
just you know some people are just like
oh Nina raped that poor table other
people are like oh the table wanted it
to happen but you know it wasn't exactly
like that it was more complicated just
like life is right so I really
appreciate you know your take on this
and you are loved we love you we love
having you here and on the Discord and
yeah
just thank you very
much hands the Oscar to the table
now puts it on the table
that that was
beautiful ah table lives matter guys
zero
say God I agree oh best streams these
are the best streams I don't know I
don't know if you guys agree but I don't
know PewDiePie stream sometimes and
stuff but I feel like PewDiePie will not
have table [__] talking about his
traumatic experience on his channel
PewDiePie will say more politically
correct things than we do politically
correct memes those exist I said
PewDiePie will say more politically
correct things Oh I thought you said we
need more politically correct memes I'm
like okay sure I don't I don't know if
those exist
but I'm sure they do that that'd
actually be pretty great just like not
funny memes just like
intentionally is it a requirement to be
funny for it to be a meme exactly that's
what makes it
funny uh r
about codeia season 3 release date we
don't know yet there's no official
release date all we're checking the
website daily and all we see so far is
merchandise promotions and promoting the
special DVD The Anniversary DVD that's
coming out in April but we will keep you
posted on this channel as soon as we
have some news we will have a video out
on it we will live stream about it
discuss it so stay tuned we will let you
know as soon as we know
something that's so funny Eno is like
the politically correct meme
movement yeah Eno's been crushing in
today good work Eno she's been crushing
it been funny been
entertaining great work great work Eno
is always number
one and table Coon's
heart yeah in table Coon's heart
probably vector's
[Music]
heart I see what you're doing here but
Vector this is why you're in Shadow
you're not going to get
usive Amelia is like cookie is number
one so yeah Amelia's th ready to throw
down cookie and chill baby shout out to
cookie and
chill also devil devil the rebel says
how to ruin code Gia season 3 may change
the artist and make everyone a wly
Agreed 100% that would ruin codeos for
me everybody just gets uh chibified
chibified yeah like Chi oh okay I didn't
know what you meant that that makes
sense that'd be dope that would R for
sure you us okay yeah season three code
g us that wouldn't ruin anything yeah no
one cares what we look like but animac
if like for example for me personally I
feel like aliens could easily ruin it
depending how they do
it so for me it would like
definitely I could see like them
advancing maybe fighting in space but
aliens it it really depends how they do
it because aliens can easily [__] [__]
up just look at Indiana Jones it was a
great series that
NOP well perhaps the aliens attacked
aliens would not aliens might ruin it
but Australians would definitely not
ruin it they would make it better
then again Australians are kind of
aliens all in the I'm kidding I'm
kidding Australians are great y'all are
great great by says even though we're
not a cult if they ruin season 3 are we
going to take over sunrise's offices and
I think occupy Sunrise is going to
happen I think it's going happen so I
thought that we were going to offer
sacrifices to the gods and ask that they
curse them no no that would be cult
we're not a cult we're not a cult we are
not a cult
anime Recon is in the house he says of
course Recon hash recon noico what's up
anime Recon Goen have you watched anime
Recon video yet yes but my father is
here our father so I don't know what's
going
on okay huge news guys anyways hey
dropping it
down there are no boundaries in my room
it looks like only the office has
boundaries
but um I feel okay because Mac usually
has fun people walking older brother
privileges so you watched Recon video
yes yes I
did um it was fun
times how' you like that clad
remix it was cool it was cool like you
got to be careful when you're remixing
clad because it's so [__] good I I
thought it was more than cool I thought
it was amazing but yeah I
like I I I think you guys should check
it out um I'm not gonna like go crazy
but I think you guys should check it out
was good you're undering it I love
it so code guos
ruining on the topic of Clan ad have a
crossover where oh
boy how could we [__] this up
uh
ma started and didn't even think about
where he was GNA go this is how they'd
[__] it up so code guos would go through
the third season with lch dead and
then all of a sudden we'd see all these
orbs and then everything would go back
to before he died don't even J man don't
even joke like that was a bad ending or
something it's not at all because it it
established it but codas didn't
establish a few people have been saying
that oh the clat after Story ending is
to Dex Machina no because it was
established from day one the first
episode had a picture of the other world
and that was all setting up guys like
that other world would be pointless if
that ending didn't happen it was set up
from the beginning that was not DX
makina but in code guos it would be
because there was nothing established so
far I agree and don't and don't wor it
goes and the people people are allowed
to be very very wrong but we're very
very right we're going to make a video
we're going to make a video Kad ending
explained where we talk about why it's a
brilliant perhaps the most brilliant
ending in all of anime I'm going to make
one too but it's just going to me be me
crying in front of a camera for like a
solid 30 seconds and then I also suggest
you do one for Evangelion anim yeah we
might have to we might have to because
of
Goen okay but I will I will contribute
but I will fact check the [__] out of
you so just so you know yeah well you
can do a you can do a response video my
brilliant perfect video if you want you
want to embarrass yourself whatever man
I'm always to embarrass myself I think
everyone knows that by now I think
that's a good point to have one CH to
have the same channel release a video
and then a response to that same video I
think it's
hilar it's never been done I feel like
we're gonna have anime going versus
uproar it's gonna be crazy no we had a
we had like way back in the day like not
way back in the day but like a year ago
or more uh we had like what was it
called anac like where we
argued it was there was a name for it I
forget what it growing up with was just
it we talked about anime stuff and like
there were arguments and like my best
friend and like animac argued over main
stream anime whether it's like worth
your time and stuff so we had like these
kind of setups where we argued with each
other yeah but now we're much more
sophisticated so it's going to be much
yes that's true yeah now instead of
arguing through uh each other's faces
argue through YouTube videos yeah yeah
exactly and by the way guys so yeah new
video on C2 coming out tonight uh
sometime soon how how how much time you
think goes in I'm saying I'm saying
before five because you know with
editing you never know what snag you
could hit but like definitely before
five could be sooner okay so before five
Eastern Standard Time expect the new
video on C2 goes be uh 10 minutes
compact but a lot of information in
there so if it isn't Rel before five EST
I'm blaming you gozen yeah you gave the
time this is all Goen this video was all
goes and he wrote the script and
everything so yeah this is his baby if
it's great then it's ours if people
don't like it
then it was a Goen thing I cleaned my
hands everyone make sure to go and
dislike
yes the video will be about C2 facts
about C2 interesting facts that you
might not have known mystery mysterious
stuff so yeah not not only that you
might not have known but that you
probably didn't know and me I learned
some new stuff too so definitely check
it out yeah and if those of us at anime
uo learn something new and you know what
nerds we are for Kos then you know that
you're probably going to learn something
new too so yeah look out for that it's G
to be great by the way don't forget to
check out maut Vector Maximus and Sinai
blizzard on YouTube they make videos
Vector less so
than the other once I get my PlayStation
I'm going to start live streaming okay
yeah okay but yeah definitely make be
sure to subscribe to those guys you know
you you know them you love them you love
to hate them they're great so links are
in the description be sure to check them
out also of course if you want to join
the Discord server the link is in the
description that's where we chat on a
daily basis spend way too much time
there and looks like Soul Maka just
joined us
s 10 hours
later
gosh how's everyone everyone good doing
great I'm awful we so we had the most
emotional recount of table's uh
experiences with Nina earlier you missed
it is it oh
damn someone has to like time stamp that
that
[__] that was that was one of the
funniest things I've ever heard I'm not
going to lie and I just put him on the
spot too that's that's amazing I I see
how it is so you I tell you a
heartwarming story you laugh at it say
It's the funniest thing you've ever
heard you know what no I'm done forget
you I'm
out oh oh my God he actually left
okay you
got vector's also offended on behalf of
the he doesn't take [__] from no one and
that's why we love him okay oh damn
what the hell just [__] happened yeah
what just happened I just come in here
and what the hell just like I missed the
bum and everything God damn it what
happened you'll have to go back and
watch the recording oh definitely
definitely um yeah shout out I know it's
you anime Recon is saying that we should
watch sort our online original scale
Recon think that they have their own
marketing campaign I don't think you
need to uh market for them but I
probably will end up seeing it for
sure I might watch
it yeah some point Clifford says is
there an SE ordinal scale dub yet I
don't think there is usually the dub com
months later yeah it's usually about six
months six to eight months after they
they usually release the dub unless they
deem it extra special like how they do
some series and they release a dub same
time as the uh sub then they've got to
get Bryce Penbrook away from his
extremely extremely busy voice acting
schedule that he definitely has good
stuff Bryce Mr P shout out to Bryce he's
probably watching the stream probably I
told him it was today we're we're tight
we're
tight um someone said something oh yes
deep voice AK snle is
here during before the other stream
started before r cafe started uh two
days ago he used two accounts he was
using a snowly account and a deep voice
account to argue with himself and people
who didn't realize he was the same guy
were like hey guys relaxed and I was
like he's the same guy he's trolling you
he's trolling you in the
chat all the
trolls any other ways to ruin cod season
3 except laugh at table [__] until he
freaks out and leaves I think we should
hear what soaka has to
say okay right okay ways to ruin T um
sorry not table um we know how to
ruin I
noticed I noticed um yeah I don't know
let's see worst ways to ruin it I think
is to make Louch some
overpowered Godlike figure I think that
would ruin it I I wouldn't want to see
anything like that cuz I think that when
they change the stakes like that it no
longer becomes the same thing kind of
like with um death not the first half it
was the stakes of him like trying to get
his goal done but trying not to get
caught at the same time but then the CH
the the stakes had changed in the second
half and the second half was just not as
good because his goal was basically
already achieved now and then it was
just the case of him getting caught or
getting like getting it proven that it
was him yeah I mean so it
like as most people know who agree with
me like Goen you know the second half of
death not just wasn't as good because
mainly due to those Stakes that had
changed so I wouldn't want to see like
Stakes change too much I understand that
okay he'll probably have immortality
which that alone will change certain
Stakes um but so long they have like a
counter measure for it like maybe they
take um Jeremiah Z and then they can use
that to then cancel immortality in a way
because it is a manufactured geese and
not then Bound by the actual rules of
gear and cod so maybe they could use
something like that but yeah I just yeah
I don't see too much of drastic change
we know we know that uh C2 has been
captured before so there's definitely
still there can still be high stakes
even if he's a mortal right they can
definitely still capture
him there can still be Stakes but I mean
they change too much it kind of takes
away from what it was originally like
like Sword Art Online for
instance yeah especially swordart online
oh man they're playing all the games now
like they're gonna like literally it's
like a let's play with
an all right guys so today we're gonna
play this completely different game
we're gonna play this how's it going har
my name's
Kito we're
playing wa Autumn Hamilton in the chat
why you you so angry bro why you so
angry he's just swearing at everybody
relax man we're just having a good time
here we're just having a good time
doesn't relax Purge him Purge him with
fire um yeah another thing as well to uh
balance the immortality I mean all they
need is an enemy with a gears in both
eyes and then that means L essentially
can
die as well as
C2 yeah true
I mean that's what they need because if
it's true that K
Kito if it's true that Louch got his uh
gu code from Charles because he was able
to kill him even though Charles is not
his contractor then another guos user
with a powerful guos could kill someone
with code right so that that the stakes
are still high yeah yeah it's even then
yeah yeah yeah so yeah I mean so long
they got something like that then yeah
um it's all good and plus I mean we
don't know whether or not all Cod users
on the planet or um gear users are
actually dead cuz I mean there was
obviously others like referred to in um
Oz you know the mang got us but I mean
even if we just look at only the anime
only there's that whole Research Center
and yeah we know okay it got wiped out
and stuff but how do we know that there
are not other survivors from that
research center maybe they're the ones
start whatever begins in the third one
you know obviously whoever it is needs
to know also about those like top secret
experiments that was done with Jeremiah
which was done through that research
center so obviously there must be
surviving members somewhere I would say
it would help balance it you know um
Helen says she looks forward today when
one day we do one of these code g
streams and all of us are cosplaying as
code gas characters I promise we will do
that one day one day that will happen
I'm screwed who could I be the only the
only person I could be is
V
yes dreams come
true there are some images that no one
in this world should see and soul
cosplaying Veta is
one I am more upset than you know right
now
just let it happen man just just let it
pointed out a good good thing that would
mess it up is if Colin got guos and
killed C2 that would definitely [__] it
up what like she takes her code like
c2's code exactly I'm I'm down for for a
Superman character eating the
dust C2 was there from the beginning
like she was there
when how much of an impact that would
have how much things would change I
don't know I can't even move on how
could the L move
on go go and many of shippers would be
but hurt if C2 dies oh man so many
that's insane who wouldn't be but her
like no I don't want any main character
suzaku
please I I will survive if suzaku please
I'm actually he's a main
character we're actually hearing people
say that like stop killing anime
characters right like we've actually
like I've heard some people making that
argument so stop killing wuss it's
interesting it's interesting that we
come to the point where now now people
are actually before we were like why is
no one dying now it's like
almost we're like heading to the other
direction so yeah hopefully we don't
lose anyone huge in
codeos you know kill everybody important
just do it Hamlet Hamlet confirmed but
by the way guys don't forget to leave a
like on the stream if you like these
streams and we have a great time always
doing them such a pleasure don't forget
to check out the guys in the description
melot son blizzard AKA table and Vector
Maximus uh don't forget to check out the
Discord as well because it's a blast
every time and after this we're going to
continue the discussion on the Discord
I'm thinking that we end the stream soon
so that we can get to work so that Goen
can what you gonna do
video the C for that and another thing
to look out for is again we're
really amazed and so grateful that we
reached over 9,000 guys it's insane it's
almost
more for that for all you guys for the
people so stay tuned for that and of
course we're approaching that big 10,000
Mark it's like five digits five 10,000
that's like almost a million like we're
we're getting there man we're getting
there it's basically a million just
missing a few zeros that's it it's it's
just as unbelievable it's pretty cool
it's pretty
cool yeah it it's you know it's just a
number a few zeros and there you go yeah
is basically like the same difference as
going from one to a 100 so you know yeah
it's it's like a Mac you know Mac logic
we can just add draw zeros on right
there you go see Max videos that's a
signature he just likes adding no
subscriber that's it like I've got I've
got way more subscribers than any of you
now it's all I had to do is draw some
zeros
on yeah I app I appreciate your humor
man
I oh ATU just just the right pinch of
troll I love it
um yeah anyone else want to say anything
before we sign off and yes soul I know
you came in late but you came in late
man you came in like an hour and 15
minutes late what can I do did yeah no
way
remember did it unless the British don't
do day light savings time no no we do
daylight savings but we ain't done it
yet well ours was like last week so yeah
we did already so may might be different
again for hell how do I not know
anything okay yeah sleep or depends
where you are on the planet in it how
the when the sun like will affect you I
guess yeah daylight saving time was last
Sunday yeah like
how that stuff so yeah yeah it changed
for North America it changed as soon in
Europe I actually know that too because
in Serbia it's the same deal so yeah
that's that's then the confusion
so right
okay sorry Soul rip Soul it's all right
it's okay just rip soul out there yeah
sorry sorry next week and
we just goes and
cries I'm gonna go join table now yeah I
know you sound like d we just we just
rag on everyone can't believe he didn't
come back that's that's I going to go
cry on the table
[__] he's there he's there to support
you oh
c there he is in the chat he's like
first
dayaka no but yeah there is no release
date yet guys for season 3 we're
checking every day as soon as we have
release date information we will let you
know on this channel we will have news
uh video up we're going to be live
streaming discussing it so stay tuned we
checking daily uh there is news updates
on the website about merchandise but not
nothing specific yet about release dates
and when we do have anything we will let
you know I can't wait for some info
it'll be fun to talk about it uh stream
about it it's going to be very cool so
yeah we're waiting on that and also
we're looking at other animes to S
deadly s season 2 one punch man season 2
we're waiting for that rezero season 2
announcement uh yeah lots of lots of
stuff should be happening sometime soon
so we are waiting for
it
W yeah so is that everything guys no one
else has anything else to add before we
call it a
day no sry I'll catch everyone in
Discord yeah yeah we're going to be
continuing the fun in the Discord if you
want to join us if you haven't already
link is in the description always a
great time in the Discord thanks
everyone for coming again for coming
here every week hanging out with us
chatting with us taking time out of your
day to be part of the community it means
a lot to us the channel has been growing
which is amazing the community has been
growing which is even more amazing
because you know the reason me and Goen
got into this was the community we
didn't get into this to get views and
things without people actually being a
part of this without them actually
contributing to what the content we make
helping us make our content better and
the fact that we created a community it
means so much more than just having
passive subscribers and Views it's it's
fun it's great we make friends we meet
people from all over the world and we
hang out with them they discuss things
anime theories memes whatever it's it's
just such a pleasure like I always love
doing this love these streams love
hanging out with you guys chatting with
you guys such a
pleasure well said I I think you
captured it beautifully very thankful
for over 9,000 and let's let's keep
going guys let's see how far we can push
this yeah it would have been funny if
Goen was like I disagree with everything
you just said it's all about the views
man it's all give me all the money it's
all about that YouTube money
yeah but yeah thanks again guys always
such such a great time and of course you
guys that can come to the stream Mac
Vector Soul table [__] uh we'll miss you
table [__] um yeah like taking time out
of your day too it's such a pleasure
always having you on and chatting with
you you guys are great guys table [__]
Oscar Oscar nomination for
sure hash pray for
table
come back one day great okay let's get
to where it goes a new video has to come
out soon but until next time see y space
Cowboys
Bang